は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
今日は。。。とんでもないゲストが来ております！
どうぞ！！
草）ん～下から来たぁあ
は）草彅剛さんです！よろしくお願いしまあぁす！！
草）お願いします～はじめしゃちょー（（握手））
は）よろしくお願いします～！！
草）観てますよ～
は）ぼ、僕もよく～も～ほんとにっっっ（歓喜）
草）よろしくお願いします～！
は）お母さんが。。サインくださいって言ってました草）あ、本当？
は）はい、ということで今日は草彅さんが来ているということで、どうやら。。
草）はい
は）YouTuberデビューを！
草）そうなんです！私、YouTuberとしてですねぇ、今後活躍していこうかなぁと思ってまぁす！
は）おっほぉ～！なるほどなるほどなるほど！
草）はじめしゃちょーとかぁ。。なんかもうすごく。。YouTubeの世界で。。
は）いやいやいや
草）もう有名なので。。いろいろ今日教えてもらおうかなぁと思って
草）観てますよ～もういろいろと。。
（ひゅんひゅんひゅん）
草）今日は何を教えてくれんですかねっ？↑
は）はい！。。あのYouTuberってこう。。なんか。。デビュー作品というか。。
この動画で有名になったみたいなのがあるんで、
草）はい
は）僕のその動画が、、、「スライム風呂」っていう。。
草）はぁい！
は）スライムを、、　　草）観ましたよ～
は）あ、観ました？
草）はぁい！！
は）せっかくデビュー。。
草）そうですねぇ　　　は）されるということなんで、
は）いっしょにやってみませんか？！！
草）やりたいですねぇ！！
は）やりますかぁ！！
は）ということで！今日は草彅さんとスライム風呂作っていきたいと思いまぁああすっっ！！
草）やったぁぁあっはっはっは～！！
（（（何かを企んでいる様子。。。）））
（ぴゅぴゅぴゅん！）
草）イケメンだよね！？
草）。。。すごく
は）いやいやいや
草）別にYouTuberにならなくてもよかったんじゃ...?
は）っいやいや（笑）
草）そんなことない？
は）ぜんぜんそんなっ！ただの。。
草）あ、そう（笑）あははは
は）一人入れるプール。。ぐらいの！
大きなスライムを作っていきたいと思います！
草）はぁ-
い！ は）まず準備するのは！
は）お水！！　　草）はい
は）３０L！あと、
は）洗濯のりが。。３０L！
草）おおっ！！
草）スライムの作り方わかってんだねぇ！
は）一応流れは！
あっ！
草）ここに座って。。ていいんですか？
は）僕が持ってくるんで！！（肩ポンポン）
（現場笑い和み）
は）こちらが水！だいたい３０Lぐらいです
こちらが洗濯のり３０Lぐらいになります！
混ぜていきましょう！
草）ほおぉい！
草）じゃぁぁあああっ！
（早送り）
は）はい！いい感じだと思います！！
草）これ、入れていきましょう！
は）。。草彅さんって
草）はい
は）なんて,お呼びすればいいですか？
草）あ、もうあの～。。
つよぽんでいいですよ～
は）つよぽんでいいんですか！
草）結構入りますねえ！（疲れ）
もうちょっとだぁ！！
は）きつぅいっ！
は）ラストですかぁ？
草）ラストかなぁ？　は）ラストですねぇ！
草）じゃあ！ラスト！！
入れますよお～！！
草）いぃ～～～
は）。。しゃぁああ！！
草）やったぁ！入りましたぁあ～
は）はぁい！！ここで一番終了でぇす！！
草）うぃいいい～
は）これで！今からこのスライムに色を付けていきます！
草）色を！　　は）はい！
は）つよぽん好きな色は何色ですか？
草）ん～、そうですねぇ
やっぱスライムって言ったら緑なんですけどぉ～
草）紫っ!(?)あははっ
なぁんで聞いたんだよぉ～！！
は）赤と青を混ぜると、、、
紫になるんで
草）お～お～
草）やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
草）おおぉ～！！やばいねぇ！
は）ちゃんと,紫ですねぇ！！
草）紫だねぇ！
は）はい続いて次なんですけどもお～
ホウ砂（ほうしゃ）という砂みたいなものがあるんですけども
草）はい
は）これをお湯に溶かしていきます
草）お～なるほど！
は）１５Lのお湯に、１２００ｍｇの（正；１２００ｇ）ホウ砂をぶち込んで、
溶かしていきます
草）うん、とけてきた　　は）あ、溶ける溶ける！
は）はい、これでホウ砂水溶液は完成です
は）紫色いの水にホウ砂を混ぜたお湯を混ぜて、
完成です！！
草）はぁい！
は・草）せ～の！
草）まぜろぉおお～！！
草）混ぜろ混ぜろ混ぜろ×１０００
草）これは使いどころだぁああ！！
（（早送り））
草）きっもちわりいぃい！！あははっ
は）固まってきた固まってきた！！
草）やっべぇ！！なにこれぇ！！
は）あ、いい感じいい感じ！！
草）ふぅ～！！↑
草）うっわなにこれきっもちわりいぃい！！ｗｗ
草）すっげぇ！固まってきたぁ！！（テンあげ）
は）いいですいいです！！　　草）なにこれぇ！！（ｎ回目）
は）ん～、いい感じだと思います！
は）これ大成功ですよ！
（真剣なまなざし）
草）１００点！？ほんとぉ？！
草）えっへへへへ（ご満悦なご様子）
スライム～！
は）はい！ということでスライム無事完成でぇ～す！！
草）やったぁ！！
は）はい、というわけで、スライム作ったんですけども～
草）じゃあ、はじめしゃちょー。。
草）。。。。入る？
は）いやいやいや。。。
ここは！！
は）ここはもう是非！
僕入ったことあるんで～
草）あ～そう。。。
は）是非～一度～体験していただけるとうれしいです
草）あ～そうだよねぇせっかくだもんねぇ　　　　　は）はい
草）じゃあちょっと、
は）はい！！
草）入ろうかぁ！！
は）おねがいしまぁす！！
（ぴゅぴゅぴゅん！）
草）じゃあ師匠！
は）はい！
草）準備整いました！
は）似合ってます！！
草）ありがとうございます！
は）つよぽんさんの
草）はい
は）YouTubeデビューを記念して！！
は）是非　　草）スライム風呂に！
は）はい！　　草）はい！
は）入っていただけると嬉しいです！！
草）はい！
は）せっかく入るんで
三脚にのっかって、、
上って、
ぶぅううんって
草）そうですよねぇ！ただ入るだけじゃつまんないっすもんねぇ
は）そうなんすよっ、ちょっと企画的な問題で。。
草）そうっすよねぇ％＄＄％＆’（＄＃？？
草）て〜って〜って〜!!みたいな
は）そう！そう！
は）ためていただいて（笑）
草）じゃあこれでいいっすか？
は）はい！じゃあお願いしあすっ！！
（（準備中））
（ドクドクドクドクドクッ）
【ボォォォオオオオンッ）×５
草）っっびっくりしたぁあああ！！
草）ドッキリ？！これぇ！！
は）ドッキリ大成功おおおおおお！！
草）あぶなくね？！？？！？はじめしゃちょー！！ｗ
草）めちゃくちゃこわいじゃぁん！！
は）天井やばい天井やばい！！
くさ）何入れたの～？！
は）あの～。。グリネード入れましたｗｗｗ
草）爆弾じゃんだってｗｗｗ
は）ｗｗｗｗｗ
草）あなた！！怖いことすんのねぇ！！
は）すいませんでしたぁぁぁぁあああ！！
（愉快なBGM）
は）びっくりしました？
草）びっくりしたよ～
は）っっっしゃあああ！！
草）え、中入んなくていいの？ww
は）いやはいりましょ！
草）ｗｗｗいやもういいよっ！　　は）えぇ～ｗｗｗ
草）これ以上ないもんｗｗｗ
は）YouTubeデビューを記念して！！。。。入ってください！！
草）いきまっす～！！　　は）３，２、ｒｙ（（
は）あっ！！
（現場笑い声であふれる）
は）おめでとうございまぁぁぁす！！
草）どうもありがと～～～～！！！
ありがと～～!!
ありがとう～!!
草）あの、この模様はAbemaTVの７２時間テレビで皆さん流れますんでぇ！！
草）ぬけなぁい！！ｗｗ　　は）あははｗｗｗ
草）皆さんお楽しみにぃ！！!!
は）お楽しみにぃ！！!!